tonight democrats they are in a full
panic their socialist policies are a
disaster their poll numbers are
imploding their president is a dishonest
corrupt and cognitive wreck and their
war on free speech is now being
challenged in a huge way by elon musk
who's attempting to take over your
favorite social media platform that is
twitter we'll have a lot more on that
later in the program but first we're at
the beginning of what is another long
weekend away for the white from the
white house for the leader of the free
world today before jetting off to camp
david joe biden took some time
to blame the war in ukraine and all of
his failures on somebody
take a look
putin's invasion of ukraine has driven
up gas prices and food prices all over
the world
ukraine and russia are the one and two
largest wheat producers in the world
we're number three
they're shut down
we saw that in yesterday's inflation
data
what people don't know is that 70
of the increase in inflation was the
consequence of putin's price site
because of the impact on oil prices 70
percent
we need we need to address these high
prices and urgently
for working folks out there
all of that is a complete and utter lie
and by who's he shaking hands with just
her shake there's nobody there
we're nearly 15 months into biden's
presidency
everything is going wrong and i mean
everything i can't name a single thing
that's going right by the way anybody
surprised biden cannot even do simple
fundamental basic tasks he turns around
who's no nobody there to shake his hand
and he keeps his hand out there are you
kidding me meanwhile inflation at a
40-year high and getting higher food
costs the cost of every item you buy in
every store is now going through the
roof energy costs well you never paid
more in history for a gallon of gasoline
and the cost to heat and cool your home
is through the roof on top of that rents
have now increased by over 17 percent
interest rates i read today it's about
five percent for a 30-year fixed well
not long ago you were getting it in the
twos they're rising fast real wages are
down by three percent and biden's green
new deal economy is now a living
nightmare for you the american people
for all of us but remember according to
the administration america's historic
inflation has nothing to do with biden's
trillions of dollars in new handouts and
the record-setting energy costs have
nothing to do with biden's restrictions
on oil and gas you can see right from
the charts we'll keep putting them up
and down up is down down is up in their
weird world and by the way everything
bad that happens is vladimir putin's
fault and as those graphs show that is a
lie and thankfully americans can see
through the total well
bull
shift as in adam schiff
president biden is trying to label this
putin's price hike but most americans
according to an nbc news poll are not
buying that only six percent blame putin
most believe president biden's policies
are very much to blame
all right new poll from quinnipiac to
just came out yesterday biden's approval
rating at an all-time low look at this
33 that's it his approval among hispanic
americans is even lower
26
biden is underwater by double digits in
five recent polls but americans aren't
just unhappy about the economy they also
disapprove about biden's handling of
ukraine crime covert and of course the
disaster at the southern border never
mind the disastrous pull out in the
islamic emirates of afghanistan where he
abandoned americans uh fellow green card
holders that are legally eligible to be
here left billions in high-tech military
equipment some 80 billion dollars worth
abandoning our afghan allies now tonight
as biden extends the mass mandates on
americans traveling on trains and planes
guess what preferential treatment he's
lifting all coveted restrictions on
illegal immigrants that are pouring
across the border isn't that great and
on may 23 title 42 will be lifted
preventing the federal government from
expelling migrants over covet 19
concerns and that means more massive
migrant caravans they're on the way a
majority of americans believe biden is
making a huge mistake and for good
reason because right on cue the first of
what will be many caravans is only days
away
now this problem at the border is so bad
and about to get so much worse in fact
border officials are now bracing for
more than a half a million migrant
encounters
next month alone
instead of fixing the problem
reinstating president trump's successful
border policies building the wall
bringing back remaining mexico policy
ending catching and process and release
well the biden administration they're
now considering a plan
to take va doctors out of va hospitals
so those va doctors for our vets can
assist with the ongoing crisis in other
words they'll take away doctors from our
va hospitals from american veterans to
provide their services to illegal
immigrants
does that sit right with you because
that does not sit right with me
biden and the far left climate obsessed
socialists around them they're literally
destroying the country right before our
eyes it is so bad even late night
liberal host bill maher
has issued this warning
and they won't heed it but they should
to his fellow democrats take a listen
there is a hunger for i think in america
more than anything is common sense yes
the
away from the extremes i mean when
people say to me you know you're don't
you think you've gotten more
conservative no i haven't the left has
gotten goofier yes so i seem more
conservative maybe
but like
it's not me who changed i feel i'm the
same guy i'm always saying to the
democrats just don't be the party of no
common sense
and you will be surprised at how much
amazing success you will have as opposed
to what's going to have
happen which is they're going to get
their ass kicked in november
by the way i finally agree with bill
maher and i would agree with his
assessment he's not really changed he's
never liked me i've never particularly
liked him but he's pretty smart
intelligent and democrats they'd be wise
to actually listen to him many of his
fellow democrats have gone absolutely
insane common sense is dead in this new
green deal climate alarmist religious
cult democratic party they've gone nuts
the liberals in the party have been
replaced with far left socialists who
don't believe in freedom of speech they
believe in cancer culture they believe
in woke everything they don't seem to
believe in capitalism or constitution
either they just worship all things at
the altar of climate change and they
want to fundamentally transform the
country into something that would be
unrecognizable now seven months from now
during the midterm elections it is
imperative to take nothing for granted
get to the polls send these socialists
an important message before our country
is at a point of no return it's that bad
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else